bonjour à toutes les deux
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct ce matin sur rtl france tout
d'abord une question pour vous dieynaba
diop un commentaire sur ce score très
serré de yannick jadot
écoutez je pense que ce n'est pas à moi
de commenter le choix des écologistes
nous en prenons acte et yannick jadot a
été désigné par sa famille politique
donc il sera le candidat des écologistes
ce qui me surprend c'est que dès le
début il dit qu'il va rassembler
seulement son camp alors que il a été
élu de justesse avec ça donc si dacia
curieux pour quelqu'un qui prétend aller
jusqu'à nice ouais il va devoir
maintenant prendre en compte les idées
de sandrine rousseau qui prenait un
nouveau modèle de société d'ailleurs
assez proche de la conception de jean
luc mélenchon danièle obono c'est une
bonne nouvelle
écoutez et désormais les partis eux
élevés à un candidat de notre point de
vue il faut effectivement que des débats
politiques puissent avancer jusqu'à
présent nous nous étions les seuls à
avoir un candidat et un programme
mettons dans ce débat présidentiel nos
propositions et nous croyons
effectivement qu' il est temps que une
écologie de rupture écologique de la
bifurcation écologique soit dans le
débat et permette que les choses se
clarifient je crois que la candidature
de monsieur jadot représente une forme
d'écologie de marché qui n'est pas à la
hauteur aujourd'hui d urgence de la
situation de la crise et nous aurons ce
débat ensuite ce qu'apportait madame
rousseau je crois était effectivement
très proche de ce que nous avons pu
défendre et son score montre de notre
point de vue qui lie à une volonté
d'aller plus loin que ce qu'on a pu voir
depuis quatre ans avec monsieur macron
et ce qui risque d'être la même chose
que des formes monsieur jadot danièle
obono je reste avec vous est ce que la
france insoumise espère récupérer les
voix qui sont allées à sandrine rousseau
nous ne sommes pas dans un calcul
électoraliste je crois que ce serait une
vision véritablement
petit petit de boutiquiers que de
considérer qu'on va ça à tracter des
voix ici et là nous adressons à une
majorité de la population aujourd'hui je
crois que les citoyens et citoyennes
sont largement au delà des étiquettes et
des formations traditionnelles
conscients de la crise et climatique et
de la crise écologique et nous c'est à
l'ensemble de la population où nous
adressons par rapport à ce que nous
proposons par rapport à effectivement
l'urgence d'une bifurcation écologique
d'une véritable politique de rupture qui
soit à la fois écologique et sociale qui
articule la justice sociale et la
justice climatique et nous voilà il ne
s'agit pas le dag missionné en fait
ddd base électorale ou des clientèles
électorales je crois que ce serait une
erreur que d'être dans cette danse est
dans cet état d'esprit sa princesse ça
se traduirait en fait et on a entendu le
fait qu' un certain nombre de candidats
et candidates ne sont pas dans une
logique d'être majoritaires en 2022 sont
des calculs pour plus tard nous ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas notre cas nous
adressons à la majorité de la population
qui pour qui aujourd'hui la question
écologique est il des questions
prioritaires et nous nous avons à
proposer un véritable programme de
rupture on va en parler dans le détail
de ces différents candidats dieynaba
diop même question pour vous côté
socialiste on pense évidemment à la
proximité des électorats de yannick
jadot et d'anne hidalgo vous pensez
faire cause commune peut-être pas pour
le premier tour et évidemment
il faudra de toute façon que la gauche
soit rassemblée avec les écologies si
nous voulons espérer du coup aller
jusqu'à l'elysée et à
la politique qui est menée depuis
bientôt presque 50 moi je crois que au
delà des calculs comptables ce qu'il
faut c'est un véritable ici pour la
france avec l'expérience de la candidate
qui est la nôtre et qui sera
certainement normalement désigné au dc e
d'ici peu par le whip il y a de toute
façon chez les socialistes depuis
toujours la volonté d'avoir justement
que cet écologiste pragmatique de
travail et on l'a vu aller d'algos a
participé à de nombreux chiffres avant
l'heure elle a été une des artisans tu
justement de la mise en place de la coop
21 est là mais comme j chevillée au
corps jusqu'en de manière quotidienne on
le sait alors dans sa gestion est
justement de l'a22 de paris moi je crois
que au delà des visions c'est qu'il faut
être pragmatique qu'est-ce qui fera qu
aujourd'hui nous serons en capacité de
travailler sereinement et de dire à nos
concitoyens oui il ya de l'écologie
dégâts écologiques ne sera pas utile
c'est-à-dire une écologie qui répond
d'abord à l'urgence sociale parce qu'on
sait très bien qu'il ya le problème des
passoires thermiques il ya une problème
de d'être bien logé avec la facture
énergétique on la vit encore une fois 2
du gaz du prix du gaz qui ne cesse
d'exploser dont il faut avoir des
propositions concrètes et pragmatiques
pour que le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens ne sera pas entamée
justement la lutte contre
ce que vous espérez un ralliement de
yannick jadot comme ça a été le cas
lorsqu'il s'était rangé derrière benoît
hamon lors de la précédente élection
vous savez il faut continuer à discuter
nous étions présents autour de la table
lorsque justement annonçait-il
où il avait justement demandé à ce que
toute la gauche et les écologistes
puisse discuter autour d'un projet c'est
pour ça que j'y fais chier à ses
surprises aujourd'hui ils ne veulent
assemblée que son camp finalement qui
dit il faut
écologistes et bien non il faut le
rassemblement l'ensemble de la gauche et
du pôle écologiste si nous voulons
demain que une autre vision à delà de la
gestion de la france et nous si nous
voulons répondre aux aspirations des
français qui n'en peuvent plus est ce qu
on pourrait même envisager que ce soit
ni d'algos qui ce qui se désiste en
faveur de yannick jadot en fonction des
sondages ou des résultats
ici les sondages étaient fiables
emmanuel macron comme président de la
république en ondes et multi sec et
chaud rappelle que tracera hollande
lorsqu'il a commencé sa campagne était à
3% moi je crois qu'il est trop tôt elle
pour faire les comptes d'apothicaire
sera aux françaises et aux français de
trancher bien sûr il faudra du débat il
faudra que les orientations bizarre les
autres soit clair que les françaises et
s'affichait en sachant qu'elle est le
projet que veulent les différents
candidats pour essayer toutes les
tranches ont gagné nos bono selon selon
jean luc mélenchon il y a deux gauches
irréconciliables le leader de la france
a soumis ce qui ne veut pas d'une union
hypocrite pour le premier tour et coûté
si je sautais dans les bras de monsieur
valls ou hollande tout le monde dirait
ceux là sont des hypocrites ce n'est pas
vrai ils ne peuvent pas se blairer c'est
vrai nous sommes en désaccord sur tout
il y a là deux gauches qui ne sont pas
compatibles
comment vous expliquer aujourd'hui cette
incompatibilité de ces deux gauches ce
qui n'était pas le cas auparavant
écoutez il ya quand même eu un
gouvernement de monsieur hollande et de
monsieur valls soutenue par le parti
socialiste et les parties une partie de
élevé qui a mené la politique que l'on
sait et qui a donné naissance d'ailleurs
à monsieur macron il ya quand même il
n'y a pas eu de bilan ou fait de fait de
cette politique là qui a introduit les
premières mesures antisociales je pense
à la loi travail de madame belle
connerie qui a eu les premières
politique de répression des mouvements
sociaux comme on n'en avait jamais vu
souvent on backs de 2016 justement cette
répression du mouvement social les
premières mesures qu ensuite monsieur
macron a repris à son compte vis-à-vis
de tous les mouvements sociaux suivant
il ya un bilan de cette gauche ou en
tout cas de ces mots mandat du parti
socialiste au pouvoir et qui n'a pas été
à la hauteur des attentes même des
promesses du candidat hollande et oui
encore une fois c'est cette même ces
mêmes bilans qui a donné emmanuel
matheron et qui a produit la politique
que l'on sait donc c'est pas une
question ni de personne ni encore une
fois des tickets de c'est une question
de politique quelles sont les politiques
qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
mises en oeuvre et on voit qu'il ya une
continuité et non pas une rupture entre
le mandat de monsieur hollande est celui
de monsieur macro et c'est ça qui a
dégoûté de la politique une bonne partie
de nos concitoyens et concitoyennes et
donc nous nous sommes dans une logique
majoritaire aujourd'hui jean-luc
mélenchon et le candidat constamment en
tête dans les sondages pour ce qui est
de une gauche et au delà de la gauche
même un candidat alternatif
audio matheron le pen est aujourd'hui
auxquels s'ajoutent monsieur est moins
parce que nous avons aussi montré depuis
quatre ans notre opposition
cohérente complète à cette politique de
destruction sociale et d'attentisme
écologique et que nous avons formulé des
propositions de fond qui vise à en finir
avec les politiques d'un commandement au
néolibéralisme de gestion de
du social d'une miralis et donc c'est
sûr ce c'est sûr c'est sur ça que les
choses et le débat politique doit porter
c est ce qu on est dans l'accompagnement
on est dans la gestion ou est-ce qu'on
est dans la rupture et la mise en place
d'une autre politique au service de la
population nous avons depuis des mois
proposer une stratégie d'union populaire
qui se base sur des propositions
concrètes dernièrement jean luc
mélenchon parlait d'une grande loi
d'urgence sociale par exemple nous avons
fait des propositions sur le blé blocage
des prix faire face à la crise actuelle
et nous proposons tout un ensemble de
mesures pour faire face à la crise
écologique de manière solidaire voilà ce
qui fait la différence majeure
fondamental je crois et ce sur quoi doit
se trancher débat démocratique pour pour
l'élection et où chacun et chacune devra
se poser la question quel est le vote
utile aujourd'hui et je crois la
campagne la dynamique de notre campagne
montrera le vote utile ou faire face à
la crise et puis pour battre macro le
pen et zemmour c'est le vote pour jean
luc mélenchon dieynaba diop que
répondez-vous à danièle obono est ce que
là le ps a une grande responsabilité
dans dans l'abandon en tout cas des
priorités sociales
je crois qu'il faudrait relire le bilan
du quinquennat qui ne qu'olivier fort a
fait notre premier secrétaire et vous
verrez que au contraire les deux belles
avancées sociales durant le quinquennat
michaud
moi ce qui me ce que je veux dire c'est
que hamon qui aujourd'hui qui est en
responsabilité dans les territoires
c'est parti socialiste que ce soit dans
les élections justement municipal au
département le parti socialiste reste la
première force motrice à gauche l'on lui
plaisent à tous ceux qui voudraient dit
qu'ils avaient donné un avis de décès
dès 2017 aujourd'hui je vous rappelle
quand même que carole delga et la
présidente de région la mieux réélu je
vous rappelle aussi que à chaque fois
que nous avons été au coeur du réacteur
nous avons gardé les régions que nous
nous avons fait l'une est que nous avons
été ceux qui ont pris la responsabilité
et que nous avons effectivement et que
l'on fait nous effacer les camions
lorsqu'il y avait nécessité de préserver
moi j'écris c'est que ces deux annonces
c'est sûr que nous avons l'expérience
nous avons la légitimité de terrain
aujourd'hui nous sommes le parti qui est
à gauche allez plus de responsabilités
donc je crois que si nous avions étaient
simulées et justement à et maman prend
les françaises et les français qui sont
de gauche ce ne serait que confiance or
les dernières sélections compris qu'ils
nous font confiance et qu'ils continuent
de compter sur nous pour pouvoir faire
de la gestion pragmatique de répandre
sur france les propositions dans la
contrainte nous avons été les premiers à
demander juste qu'il y ait un ajustement
d'une ouverture du rsa aux jeunes dont
la
balayer d'un revers de la main par le
gouvernement actuel qui l'avons rien à
voir avec emmanuel macron
les justes il se savait de
réaction à cette annonce de l'ancien
ministre de l'ecologie ségolène royal
qui a déclaré hier qu'elle n'excluait
pas non plus de se présenter après sa
défaite aux sénatoriales regarder
puisque le ps me rends ma liberté et que
je considère qu'il faut représenter
différemment les choses pourquoi pas je
n'exclus rien elle a incarné l'écologie
ségolène royal pourquoi pourquoi le
parti socialiste l'aurait abandonné ce
noël
alors je personne ne l'a abandonné mais
soyons clairs ségolène royal
et de positionnement
les pilotes oui nous avons reçu leurs
alliés à une centrale qui a brillamment
gagné les élections mais justement dans
sa circonscription je crois qu'il faut
aussi un moment de lui que le candidat
perpétuel arrêt a laissé la place à une
nation à d'autres personnes qui sont aux
responsabilités et qui seront justement
l'avenir de la france je crois qu'il
faut aussi sortir l 2 6-2 2-6 2-6 helix
ou adduction est équivalent constamment
revenir au pouvoir ou y accéder dernière
question très très vite danièle obono
pour une équité des temps de parole
selon fabien roussel la gauche n'est pas
divisée elle est diverse est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça et est ce qu'elle
est réconciliables
et une sable
oui et que tu as il y a toujours eu des
sensibilités différentes mais je pense
que aujourd'hui la question ce n'est pas
la gauche c'est le peuple c'est l'état
dans lequel se trouve une majorité
aujourd'hui de nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes et je crois qu'il faut
sortir de cet entre soi de ses querelles
de personnes il s'agit de s'adresser
aujourd'hui au pays il s'agit de
s'adresser à toutes celles et ceux qui
ont souffert sous les précédents
montrent a encore plus souffert sous le
mandat de monsieur de monsieur macro et
surtout les millions et les millions de
concitoyens et concitoyennes qui
s'abstiennent justement à cause du bilan
des précédents gouvernements qui ont
gouverné en continuité avec
les dogmes néolibéraux qui ont mis en
place des politiques d'austérité dans
lesquels s'inscrit la politique de
monsieur mac ronge les dix les issues de
ces alternances ps où l air et donc
c'est nous notre objectif c'est de
fédérer le peuple c'est de construire
une union populaire c'est de s'adresser
aux millions de citoyens et citoyennes
qui sont dégoûtés de la politique on m'a
dégoûté de la politique et qu'on a
dégoûté de la gauche et donc nous nous
faisons une campagne sur le fond sur le
programme pour gagner regagner à la
politique ces millions de personnes et
je crois que jean luc mélenchon est
aujourd'hui celui est en tout cas les
sondages le montrent qui est le plus en
capacité de construire cette majorité
populaire et regagner l'abstention n'a
pas parlé malheureusement ce sera
l'objet d'un autre débat merci beaucoup
dieynaba diop et merci beaucoup à vous
danièle obono d'avoir participé à ce
débat en direct sur rt france